so I'm gonna keep this brief but um a
film between my two scariest topics
which are Mexican drug cartels and
beauty pageants what do you think that's
like hot scarier day which is scarier
that isn't a good question oh my god I
would not want to be involved in either
one
I'd like do you think there's any
overlapping skill sets that uh you'd
need for both uh people skills in the
film that there's a lot of you know
smiling when maybe you are terrified
inside that's a good point is having
confidence no matter what yeah well I
noticed that um well what attracted you
originally to this story which I know
it's based on a true story of a Mexican
beauty pageant queen right right right
the original inspiration was that and
then I had thought that the idea was
really in from the Mexican border South
Texas McAllen Texas so I grew up with
that rich cultural mishmash clash you
know which I love all the things that
happen on the border I mean it's just so
unique and so when I saw this whole
border story and the chance to film it
in Mexico and Tijuana I love Mexico so
I'm like yeah let's do this
and then of course the idea of this what
a normal girl that has to find her own
inner strength to fight everything every
crazy level of new stuff that's thrown
at her you know institutions and you
know gangs and everything that she finds
that strength so I love that idea
what was it behind the decision to make
Gloria an American mexican-american is
that instead of just a Mexican beauty
pageant I I think that was a really cool
idea that the producer and the new
writer had to make it feel a little bit
more global and expanded so that you
really felt like in a way I've been
talking to people that a lot of people
feel that even a friend of mine who's
Vietnamese feels like she grew up in the
u.s. doesn't speak Vietnam Vietnamese
fluently so when she goes back to
Vietnam she doesn't quite fit into
Vietnam but she doesn't feel like she
fits in here too so that's something
that a lot of people kind of feel let
Nick's have people feeling and from all
cultures feel like what's my identity
you know and that was something that
broadened the
I really like the part where like Lena
and Gloria are talking it's almost like
they're both sort of Outsiders in both
countries yeah this is the way they feel
the original movie came out in 2011 all
right what do you think about you know
the representation and sort of the view
of how people see Americans these are
Steve Mexicans these days in America and
is that sort of an issue or something
you considered when making a movie about
dangerous criminals well um you know our
movie has a lot has a lot of Mexican
represented in the film you know her
best friend Susie
a cool little kid the brother you know
the neighbors you know all the different
people so and of course other members
and the beauty pageant and everything so
it's not like we're saying okay
everybody in Mexico it's one way by any
means but the original film had a very
passive character the the woman in the
film was quite passive and so like I was
just like screaming at the screen like
do this out thing kick butt I mean I
think that worked in 2011 but now we
want to see a woman that's really you
know has agency and is really trying to
get herself out of this tough situation
well I know there's probably not a
chance there's gonna be a sequel but
Laura was supposed to be Miss Universe
and go on to that so if there was any
chance it seems like it would be a good
place to go global yes thank you
you